antoine bonjour alors quel est le
programme aujourd'hui précisément
oui vous l'avez évoqué ces dernières
semaines les conversations téléphoniques
entre les deux présidents se sont
multipliées c'est maintenant l'heure de
se rencontrer en face à face en chair et
en os en se déplaçant aujourd'hui à
moscou emmanuel macron cherche à obtenir
un signe de bonne volonté un signal un
gage qui puisse être considéré comme un
début de désescalade de la part du
kremlin en face va dire poutine attend
des réponses aux demandes russe de
garanties de sécurité en particulier
concernant l'arrêt de l'extension de
l'otan un sujet qui n'avance pas assez
vite aux yeux du kremlin écoutez
rien de nouveau n'a eu lieu ces derniers
jours concernant le sujet des garanties
de sécurité pour la russie
un sujet que nos interlocuteurs
occidentaux préfèrent ne pas aborder
au lieu de ce sujet il préfère discuter
de manière très très exalté du problème
de la future attaque de la fédération de
russie contre l'ukraine qui selon ne
existe
à cet égard on ne peut guère dire que la
situation s'améliore
en amont de cette rencontre vous l'avez
dit vladimir poutine emmanuel macron a
dans un premier temps évoqué la
situation avec eux joe biden c'était ce
dimanche dans la soirée mais aussi avec
les dirigeants des trois pays baltes que
son l'estonie la lettonie et la lituanie
et ce dans une logique je cite de
coordination alors concrètement emmanuel
macron est attendu dans l'après-midi il
y aura quelques images montrant le
protocole d'accueil puis les deux hommes
vont entrer dans le vif du sujet les
négociations en elle-même puis enfin une
conférence de presse commune sera donnée
à l'issue de ces pourparlers alors
s'agit-il d'une énième réunion qui ne
débouchera sur pas grand chose de
concret ou bien au contraire peut-on
s'attendre à pourquoi pas une percée
diplomatique
la réponse dans la soirée merci à
beaucoup avoue antoine à claireaux vous
suivez donc pour nous cette rencontre
tout au long de l'après midi on va